hey guys
welcome to yet another video by simply
learn in today's video we shall be
talking about the best books for
programmers
before getting into the video here's a
general reminder
to subscribe to our channel and hit that
bell icon so that you can never miss an
update from simply learn
so without further ado let's jump right
into the video
if you're a coder you should also be a
good reader reading develops your mind
and the mind is your weapon a programmer
should read and understand the question
or problem
before starting the code reading skills
are equally crucial for a coder
in this video we bring a list of eight
best books for programmers
with each book having different types of
content you might wonder
how do you learn to program from books
well
books on coding or computer science can
be as fun as a course you take
the best types of programming books did
not just tell you how but explain the
why behind it
so here are some of the books every
programmer should read
note that the list of books is in no
particular order
so the first book in the list is code
complete
a practical handbook of software
construction by steve
mcconnell born in the year 1962
steve mcconnell is a famous author of
multiple software engineering textbooks
and is cited as an expert in software
engineering and project management
published in the year 1993 his book code
complete is a software development book
that provides
the most useful practical guides of
programming
it is fully updated with revised leading
edge coding concepts
and examples this book is a massive
piece of literature
with each chapter packed with techniques
and suggestions to improve everyday
programming
overall this book will help you
understand the art of science
of software construction up next we have
the pragmatic programmer
from journeyman to master born in the
year 1964
andrew hunt is a writer of books on
software development
in contrast david thomas is a computer
programmer
author and editor together they have
authored
this book which is about computer
programming and software engineering
the pragmatic programmer was published
in the year 1999
it is a collection of lessons and
recommendations for software developers
it does not present a systematic theory
but rather collection of tips on how you
can pragmatically
improve the development process the book
presents development methodologies
analogies and short stories too it
covers
various topics ranging from personal
responsibility
and career development to architectural
techniques
for keeping your code flexible and easy
to adapt
next on the list we have clean code a
handbook of agile software craftsmanship
born in the year 1952 robert c martin is
colloquially called uncle bob
he's an american software engineer
instructor and a best-selling author who
is most recognized for developing many
software design principles
this book was published in august 2008
and is a fantastic book that emphasizes
writing the code clean this book states
that even bad code
can function however if the code isn't
clean
it can bring a development organization
to its knees
this book is divided into three parts it
divides into principles and best
practices of writing clean code
and presents increasingly challenging
case studies that challenge the readers
to think about what is right with the
code and what is wrong
the third part is the payoff that
contains the list of heuristics
to sum it up if you are having an
interest in producing petticoat
this book is a must for you next we have
programming pearls born in the year 1953
john lewis bentley is an american
computer scientist
who has earned a phd in computer science
from the university of north carolina
his book programming purse was published
in the year 1986.
this book is a bit different from other
books on the list
it is delightful to read as the writing
style is simply outstanding
the concepts in the book are covered
with practical problems and effective
solutions
it challenges your understanding of core
concepts in cpu
memory and algorithms this book may not
be an ordinary book of new programming
concepts
but it is the best practical programming
book to practice and follow
with clean cut examples overall it is
the best book to practice
problems of data structures and
algorithms next on the list is the book
by three different authors
this is a computer science textbook by
mit professors
harold albison and gerald j sussman
along with julie sussman
initially published in the year 1979
this is one of the best books
to learn the fundamental programming
principles including
recursion modularity abstraction and
programming language design and
implementation
it offers a solid programming foundation
and deals with functional programming
this book was formally used as a
textbook for mit's introductory course
in electrical engineering and computer
science
it is a general programming book that
uses scheme to illustrate
the various programming concepts the
next one on the list is
cleaner code a code of conduct by
professional programmers
here's yet another fantastic book by
robert c martin published in the year
2011.
this book covers the practices
techniques and tools for true software
craftsmanship
it helps you build the attitude of a
skilled professional programmer
this book is packed with practical
advice about everything from estimating
and coding to refactoring and testing
through this book martin showed how to
approach software development
with honor self-respect and pride you
will learn
many other aspects of being a
professional programmer via
this book next we have zero bugs and
program faster
born in the year 1956 kate thompson is a
british irish writer
who is best known for children's novels
when it comes to coding
she spent two years researching every
bug avoidance technique she could ever
find her book zero bucks and program
faster
contains the best of them published in
the year 2015
this book talks about programming
improving skills and avoiding mistakes
this book helps you program faster with
fewer bugs and write more secure code
it has useful discussions stories course
references
diagrams and code samples to sum it up
if you want to quote faster with fewer
bugs you have got to get your hands on
this book
at last we have the art of computer
programming by donald e
nut born in the year 1938
donald irvin nuth is an american
computer scientist mathematician and
professor emeritus
at stanford university his book the art
of computer programming has four volumes
and was initially published in the year
1968.
it is a comprehensive monograph that
covers many kinds of programming
algorithms
and their analysis this book is top
rated and highly praised by many of the
world's top programmers
for the combined mathematical exactness
with great humor
throughout the chapters the book focuses
mainly on representing information
inside a computer
and is an excellent read for programmers
and there you go that is our list of
best books for programmers
do you have any other must read books
that you would like to add to the list
please share it with us in the comment
section below
we will be back soon with yet another
exciting and informative video
till then stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here